لم تكد ما اطلقت عليه اسرائيل مسيره
الاعلام المحتفيه بضم مدينه القدس في حرب
عام 67 لم تكت تطوير اعلامها حتى جاءت
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بفعل لا يقل استفزاز
وتحديا ليس للفلسطينيين وحدهم بل للعالم
العربي والاسلامي كليهما فما بدا
اسرائيليا صهيونيا يمينيا متشددا صار يتخذ
شكلا مؤسسيا تعبر عنه السياسه الاسرائيليه
الرسميه فهاي الحكومه التي يقودها بنيامين
نتنياهو والتي توصف بانها الاكثر يمينيه
في تاريخ اسرائيل تعقد اجتماعها في نفق
تحت حائط البراق الملاصق للمسجد الاقصى
حيث تقوم شبكه من الانفاق تضم 57 نفقا تحت
المسجد الاقصى
نتنياهو الذي يبدو منتشيا بهذه الموجه
اليمينيه قال ان المعركه لا تزال مستمره
من اجل توحيد القدس وقد اعتمدت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في اجتماعها زياده مبلغ 17
مليون دولار لميزانيه حفر الانفاق
والتنقيب عن الاثار والاثار هي ما تلح
اسرائيل في طلبه لتعزيز مقولاتها السياسيه
في القدس بحفريات تبحث عن هيكل سليمان
لاعاده بناء التصور للدوله اليهوديه
المقدسه من فسيفساء التاريخ اليهودي وهو
مسعا لم يثمر شيئا حتى الان فلم تبقى الا
القوه لفرض المقولات التلموديه على نحو ما
يفعل
وزير الامن الداخلي الاسرائيلي واضطراب
علو نبره الخطاب الصهيوني دينيا كان او
قوميا يجد تعبيراته العمليه على الارض من
خلال اقتحامات المتطرفين لباحات المسجد
الاقصى ينخرط في ذلك نواب في الكنيست
ووزراء في الحكومه في مقدمتهم بنكفير
ومشهد اليوم يقول ان التطرف الاسرائيليه
اصبح سلوكا رسميا يقف وراءه اليمين الديني
المتصاعد تيار حتى صار نيل رضاه بعضا من
وسائل التكسب السياسي كما يفعل رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو الذي قال ان بقاء
ائتلافه الحكومي وهو ائتلاف مستند الى
غلاه المتطرفين قال انه ضروري لتحقيق
توحيد القدس وامن اسرائيل
ورغم صمود الشعب الفلسطيني في صراعه
المتطاول ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وتضحياته
حربا بعد حرب وقتلا بعد قتل واعتقالا
وسجنا بعد اعتقال وسجن فان الصراع مع
اسرائيل على القدس ليس شانا فلسطينيا فقط
بل هو اسلامي بالدرجه الاولى كذلك
في زمان غير هذا الزمان كان حرق المسجد
الاقصى في عام 69 كافيا لايغاظ العالم
الاسلامي من سباته فخرجت منظمه المؤتمر
الاسلامي في العام نفسه تعبيرا عن الحاجه
الى موقف اسلامي موحد في وجه التحديات
الوجوديه
ثم دار الزمان دورته وارتقت قبضه العالم
الاسلامي على مقود التاريخ حتى توشك ان
تخرج من متنه فالتحدي الذي يواجه منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي المتحوره من منظمه
المؤتمر الاسلامي يبدو اشد خطرا من ذي قبل
فيما يتصل بالقدس والمسجد الاقصى انه
التحدي الذي يواجه المملكه المغربيه
بوصفها رئيسه للجنه القدس ويواجه المملكه
الاردنيه الهاشميه بوصفها القيمه على
الاثار والمقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه في
القدس
من يقسم معهم على الحد الادنى من النصر
يتساءل الفلسطينيون فالاقصى قضيه لا تترك
لاحد في العالم العربي والاسلامي من
خيارات شتى فاما لزومها بما يستوجب النزول
واما اللحاق بالقوم في النفق
[موسيقى]